so this is going to be a live recording
well not alive a recording of our
podcast before a live audience
these are the interns right of the
Institute senior staff when we didn't
actually invite them but they heard you
were here and in their way they just oh
we ended up in this room we were gonna
be in our dark studio no well that's
nice it's good to have it's nice to be
in front of all you people so
hypothetically we'll see how civilized
you are is an Tifa here it's good good
all right so we ready yes pretty nice to
see you so nice to see you okay start go
welcome to the femme splinters I'm
Danielle Crittenden and I'm Christina
Hoff Sommers and we are thrilled to have
the father of all manse planers in our
studio today yes a man whisperer and the
mad genius behind the intellectual dark
web whatever
welcome to the femme Slater's Jordan
Peterson thank you very much so
delighted to have you and it's an honor
to have you honor it's um and a note to
our listeners we're recording this in
front of a live audience at the American
Enterprise Institute in Washington DC
where Christina is a resident scholar
and there'll be video of the podcast as
well and we will let you know where to
find that when it's ready and we're also
grateful to AEI every week for the use
of its recording studio for the podcast
and now for an introduction though he
needs no introduction to the people here
but Jordan Peterson is a professor at
the University of Toronto and author of
many books and and poster of many
fantastic lecturers and his most recent
book has I can't keep track of how many
languages it's been translated into and
the sales just a phenomenally successful
book tour in fact my first question is
really about your tour you look pretty
good for somebody who's visited what a
hundred cities in the past
she's January 23rd I don't know how you
do it
and mostly flying
well what do you do for fun what do you
ever get to relax in brief moments and
what do you do go on Twitter and oh god
yes although I would qualify that as
relaxing and I try to you know forestall
that temptation as much as possible well
I have the Ottoman a bit of time that I
could spend with my wife she does travel
with me and so you know we've had we we
try to take some time to walk around the
cities that we're in and see what we can
its we're usually not at any given place
for more than a day or two and they're
usually pretty packed up with well
whatever is associated with the lecture
and then with press that the publishers
usually arrange well I heard you
interviewed in Sweden you were in
Stockholm and you were had a half an
hour to visit the city with your wife
yeah and you know you loved it but that
you know it's yeah well you tell you
take your breaks where you get them well
the thing is is that the the lecture
tour is unbelievably positive yes and a
lot of this is is ridiculously positive
you know like so if I'm going out on the
streets now or in cafes or you know
airports I meet people all the time and
they're always polite and they're always
happy to see me and they always have
some very touching story to relate and
and then the audience's themselves are
very positively predisposed to whatever
it is that we're doing together and so
that makes it a lot easier to stay
motivated and and and to continue right
you know I mean it's demanding because
everything's scheduled so tightly and
and I do a different lecture every night
every time I go I find that amazing
because I give a lot of lectures and I
anguish over every word and then I have
another one and it I you go up without
notes yeah well I have a large
collection of you know things that I
know what how to talk about and usually
what I try to do is to formulate a
problem before the like and so I'm
addressing a specific problem right and
then I can track how I would set up the
argument and then I walk through it but
part of its also in
to formulate the argument on the fly you
know to make the question what would you
say to formulate it more precisely and
to make a more precise and engaging
answer and then I can use the audience
to judge whether or not that's that's
happening and so it's also a real
challenge to do that so I enjoyed that
and it's a excellent intellectual
workout and I've been recording the
lectures and I've been using fair some
of them to write the first draft of the
chapters for my next book and for books
after that and so you know I'm I'm able
to maximize the what would you say the
utility of doing this at each event and
and my wife seems to be particularly
well suited to traveling like that she
actually enjoys it quite a bit and and
is a very stable person and so that's
also helpful so and you know it's nice
to have an extra brain along because
things are scheduled so tightly that we
don't ever have any room for error yes
well we're going to I can't
I don't know how intellectually rigorous
we plan to be with you today because we
know that when you ever you're on one of
these platforms you're talking about
your ideas but on the fence planners we
want to hear more a little bit more
about Jordan Peters than the man that's
desperately in definitely want to hear
about your wife Tammy yeah and also your
so well known for your views on men or
how your ideas have been taken up so
enthusiastic by young men but we want to
talk to you about women yep that's good
so but one of the things you and I share
is that we both grew up in Canada I
promised Christine I would not do my
Canadian accent while you were here but
you grew up in rural Alberta I grew up
in Toronto and you are what the
country's most famous guru now since
Marshall McLuhan
um and but is the fact that you came
from Canada have any effect on your
views do you think has it formed you in
any way I mean what did what would it
wouldn't would it be the same if you
think you'd grown up in rural Texas how
is Canada country
you're welcome she's always looking for
the Canadian well I think the particular
part of Canada I grew up in probably was
formative to some degree I mean the town
I grew up in was only fifty years old
you know and the particular part of the
world that I grew up in was really the
last settled part of the North American
Prairie this was outside of Edmonton
yeah both 400 miles north of Edmonton Oh
400 miles yeah yeah it's right short so
it's a shortcut yeah so the Prairie
number the Prairie stretches up that far
north it stretches up farther north in
Alberta than it does anywhere else in
the North American continent and so we
were at the tip of viable farming
essentially and so it was it was a new
place and it was a rather raw place and
it was a it was a rather harsh place in
many ways be especially because of the
winter and it was fundamentally a
working-class place although a
prosperous working-class place right
because most of the industry there was
related to the oil and gas industry on
although it was cyclical when things
were good working-class people could
make a very good living this was during
seventies so yeah to be a kid in 400
miles outside a small town yeah I liked
it when I was a kid I wouldn't say it
was as fun when I was a teenager I'm but
I'm not convinced that you know the
majority of people who are teenagers
necessarily have the most wonderful time
of it I think adults often look
backwards at the past through
rose-colored glasses I think that's what
the cartoonist Trudeau accused Reagan of
doing continually um Gary Trudeau the
American Institute oh no no there's no
use for it in your book was teenage
wasteland yeah yeah yeah
but it's Canadian as' just juice how
does that formed you or affected you if
at all maybe it didn't it's hard to say
I mean I've lived in lots of different
parts of Canada now and and
it's quite different I lived in well
Alberta for a while and it had this
particular flavor of existence I mean
mostly in Fairview I was striving to
leave mm-hmm and to move ahead let's say
or to move
I hesitate say up but somewhere
different somewhere more urban but
that's the case with many people I mean
the small towns all across the West in
the US and in Canada are dying
mm-hm they're down to nothing cuz
everyone's moved to the cities I lived
in Montreal for a good while and that
was interesting because it was a very
very different culture it was a culture
that was to some degree stratified by
language and by class and none of that
was true in Alberta because it was so
new that there's no class structure so
that was quite interesting right and you
worked what I loved because I think as
you say people are born in small places
everywhere and someone to leave and some
don't you said I wanted to be elsewhere
I wasn't the only one everyone who
eventually left the Fairview I grew up
knew they were leaving by the age of 12
I knew and my wife who grew up with me
on the same Street knew what's that
thing what would you call that what's
the thing that makes you want to leave
and and set you off because as you point
out there was no class system education
was cheap in Canada oh yeah it wasn't it
wasn't cost it was talking people you
were from a what middle-class yeah my
father was a teacher and my mother was a
librarian no no she had trained as a
nurse so you know we had a comfortable I
would say suburban lifestyle essentially
you know I'm moderate middle-class
suburban lifestyle that's what Fairview
looked like it looked like a suburb that
was built mostly in the ninth say
between the 1950s in the 1970s so young
Jordan and the then young Tami and you
have to tell us that story how you met
but wanted wanted more well you know I
think that's one thing that is different
to some degree about class my father and
my mother had both left two towns they
were from and they were forward future
looking people and you know most of my
friends who quit school and who didn't
attend University they didn't have they
didn't have that
since I would say that more developed
sense of a world outside of what they
knew and the other thing is that my my
father took us on long trips when I was
a kid he was a teacher and so he had
summer holidays and we drove all over
Western Canada and down into the US long
driving trips thousands of miles and you
know that also gave us the sense that
the world was a bigger place but I knew
way before I was 12 I believe that I was
off at least to university and I think
generally in your family if you're
liable to go to university people don't
even really talk about it it's just a
given that that's what's going to happen
it's it's something that you take in
with every breath almost it's it's an
it's often an unspoken expectation and
maybe people make casual reference like
well when you go to college but it's not
like there's a question about it whereas
if you're from a working-class
background especially if your family
hasn't pursued post-secondary education
that isn't in the realm of unspoken or
spoken expectation and it wasn't like
like lots of my friends including many
of them who dropped out before they hit
high school they weren't by they were by
no means the dimmest people in the class
like they were plenty smart but they
weren't oriented towards the idea of
pursuing a career that that involved
intellectual what intellectual
engagement wasn't in their worldview and
you know when you hear people on them
let's say more socialists end of the
distribution talk about barriers to
education they are often talk about cost
and sometimes cost is a barrier and it's
more than barriers day
yeah and it's more of a bear although
there's still plenty of community
colleges at state colleges where you can
drive get educated for a perfectly
reasonable amount of money but for my
friends no it was never a reason that
money was never a reason they didn't
pursue post-secondary education it was
more like a truncated view of time I
would say you know there was more of an
emphasis on the here-and-now only and
there were jobs aplenty I guess well
there was also that yeah yeah and and
well-paying jobs like it wasn't obvious
that you were in better shape back and
all
comically to go to university oh yeah
especially if you were doing something
like working on the oil rig right right
but Tom but you know that was rough cold
harsh work and it wasn't it wasn't once
you had an in you could stay employed
but it wasn't that easy to land an
entry-level job either
and so yeah well it was wise for lots of
working-class people to to work in those
jobs because they were unbelievably
lucrative mm-hmm so and they should have
been because they were very difficult
and dangerous and frigid cold and and
and rough so you know it's not like the
people didn't earn their money well just
tell us quickly like how you met your
wife you were you met her when you were
seven or eight er yeah great three thank
grade three yeah and you did you fall in
love with her in grade 3 yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
there were lots of the boys in grade 3
we're in love with her she had a whole
little crew of guys that we're perfectly
willing to follow her around and she was
perfectly willing to exploit that she
was very good at it
yeah she was very popular it's just so
wonderfully you've met his children
there were friends for a long time you
know we used to play chess together and
croquet and she's a vicious croquet
player she would I don't know if you've
ever played croquet but if it's been
your balls touch then you can stand on
yours and whack it and then the other
person's ball will oh she did vanish off
into this stratosphere and she liked to
knock it all the way down the street yes
and then she'd laugh so she she always
had a good sense of a good vicious sense
of humor it's one of the things actually
admire about my wife when when we've had
our verbal disputes which you know have
certainly happened she can string
together a sequence of insults that's so
hair-raising then you have to laugh did
she have brothers um she did she has a
brother much older 8 8 years old because
I'm quite a peaceful person and gross
with brothers you know seemed to can get
along with guys cuz come out the they
would they show love and affection by
insults yeah
and jabs and jeers and yeah and if you
and I had brother and I started learned
okay I could but if you don't have
brothers girls like oh that's so rude
that's so yeah so she was yeah well she
she she has a naturally there's maybe
cuz she's a bit naturally twist she well
and her father is quite sharp witted and
and and but he was a real town character
he's still alive huh he was a real
character in the town a real hyper
extrovert everybody knew him and he had
a pretty good wit on him and she had
some of that well it still had does have
some of that so she was a you know aside
from her acerbic humor and her ability
to whack balls and I just don't want to
go further on that description that's it
of many many things that tells us about
you what else brought what else attract
I mean you've known her pretty much your
whole life so some of the other
qualities that not just attracted you
but enable you to sustain I mean I think
every young person in this room will
want to know and maybe there isn't one
but what's the secret what's it like to
be with someone that long how do you
sustain that well I think if you're
fortunate some of its some of its good
fortune you know and I would say this is
true I've watched people in their
relationships
you know personally for a long time but
also as a professional because I've done
a lot of clinical counseling and I mean
there's some things that that need to be
a given about the relationship I would
say it doesn't hurt to find the other
person very attractive you know and
that's a mysterious thing we're not
exactly sure what it is that produces
let's say chemistry between people
although chemistry is definitely part of
what produces it there's subtle things
that attract people to one another that
are way below the level of consciousness
so for example women don't like the
older of men who have Rh blood factors
who if they had children with would be
likely to produce a stillborn infant
well that's definitely a category
match.com
well it's so strange though because
well that's a good question and you know
you know by order apparently and so
there's all wearing Cologne well that
then it would depend on what type of
Columbia our age right smell is a very
strange sense and it's very deeply tied
to very profound emotions including
memory and so you find people attractive
for reasons that you can't always
determine and so so that that was part
of it I mean I've always found her very
attractive and that continues and I I
liked her combativeness you know like I
think that there's you want someone I
think in a relationship that you can
spar with and it's partly because you
have hard problems to solve and if the
person that you're with isn't willing to
put forward their opinion then you only
have half the cognitive power that you
would otherwise have you know and
hopefully you find someone who's
interestingly different from you like
not so different that you can't
communicate and you have to be careful
of that but interestingly different and
then hopefully they have the ability and
the will to express their opinion and
and then well then it's you know then
then your interest stays heightened and
there has to be that tension in a
relationship you know people think well
I I want to get along perfectly with my
partner it's like no you you probably
don't you just get bored and then you go
looking for trouble and so you want a
little bit of trouble in the
relationship and a little bit of mystery
and a little bit of combativeness and
and the ability to exchange opinions
forthrightly and and I trust her which
is a huge element I mean when we finally
did decide to get together permanently
we were both in our later 20s and you
know one of the things that I had
learned by that point and insisted to
her about was that we had to tell each
other the truth and she took to that
whole heartedly you know and for better
and for worse
truths can be harsh does that include
like does this outfit
yeah well the truthful answer to that is
I don't answer questions that are likely
to get me in trouble so my I have a son
who'll answer honestly and it's
infuriating but then I realized if you
want the truth
talk to town well well that's the thing
you know it's it's useful to know truth
is empowering truth tellers are
charismatic and you know actually both
my sons are like brutally honest which
is disconcerting you but it's Minh see
that it has made them very formidable
and because of it people trust them and
the friendships and just it gives them
mood and you've written a lot about this
well you know if I tell my wife that she
looks good in an outfit she knows that I
mean it yeah and so there's some utility
in that and then if you're silent and
say I don't answer questions that she
goes and she knows well well sometimes
sometimes you know she'll say you know
do you like this and I'll tell her that
I don't and you know necessarily make
her happy in the moment but but if I do
say I like it she knows that I mean it
and you know I'd actually like her sense
of style a lot so it turns out that 90%
of the time it's pretty easy for me to
say look I think you look great and mean
it and you know she's a fairly harsh
standard-bearer too like she's she's
insisted that I stay in whatever
reasonable physical shape I happen to be
in you know that was that was something
that she's very demanding of and I would
say that it's the same from my side and
and we've been good at negotiating which
is you know what do you want from a
partner fundamentally what what do you
want need I mean the first thing is is
that well hopefully you like I said
you're blessed with the fact that you
find each other attractive and I think
it's very difficult for the relationship
to begin or proceed or sustain itself
without that but having that then what
do you want well you want someone that
you can trust you want someone that you
can build a view of the future with and
you want someone that you can negotiate
with and that's very hard
negotiate with people because they have
to tell you what they think they have to
know what they want or figure it out
they have to tell you what they want
they have to be satisfied when they get
what they want which is also a very
difficult thing to manage and you have
to continually update that because your
life goes through different stages and
well in your attraction wanes as we all
know it our stage of life not fatally
necessarily for yourself but but no but
you will go I mean you will not be
twenty five forever so so that that has
to be renegotiate yeah well and you have
to work at that too right you know and
and that's something that people also
don't understand because they tend to
think that well that that all romantic
interaction should be spontaneous it's
like well if that's your theory then you
might as well just give up right now if
you're gonna get married because that
like the only reason you can think that
is because you don't have enough
responsibility to make romantic
entanglement virtually impossible and
what happens when you're married
especially when you have little kids is
that and and you both have a job let's
say is you're so busy that the
probability that you're going to find
time for spontaneous mutual interaction
is decreases to zero and so if that's
what you're hoping for then you're never
going to have it and so what you have to
do is you have to make time for each
other and you know if you're dating when
you're establishing a relationship well
you put some effort into it you know you
you decide that you're going to go out
for dinner and you dress up to some
degree and you know you try to present
yourself to each other in some halfways
mutually acceptable manner and you hope
that there's going to be a positive
consequence of that that you're going to
find each other attractive but then
people somehow think that once they're
married that the same amount of effort
isn't necessary and that's wrong I would
say more effort is necessary on the same
front and you have to think it through
it's like you know if you don't want to
be bitter about the intimate element of
your relationship how much time do you
have to spend together each week and my
my rule of thumb sort of derived from
clinical observations is that you need
to spend 90 minutes a week with your
partner talking and that means you're
telling each other about
your life and staying in touch you know
so that you each know what the other is
up to and you're discussing what needs
to be done to keep the household running
smoothly and you're laying out some
mutually acceptable vision of how the
next week or the next months are going
to go together right so that that keeps
your narratives locked together like a
like the strands in a rope you need that
for 90 minutes or you drift apart and
you need to spend intimate time together
at least once a week and probably more
like twice and that has to be negotiated
and if you don't negotiate it and if you
don't make it a priority then it won't
happen in all likelihood and then well
well then you don't have it that's a
catastrophe because there's not that
many things in life that are you know
intrinsically what would you say
engaging and meaningful and pleasurable
and also bonding all of that and if you
let that go then well part of you dies
and part of the relationship dies and
well then there's always the possibility
of becoming attracted by alternative
entanglements which which you would do
if you had any spirit left right I mean
that's the thing is if well if you're
not if you're if your relationship at
home is entirely unsatisfying sexually
what are you supposed to do with that
nothing he's supposed to just bear it I
mean in one way the answer is yes
because it's your marriage but another
way is well what that's all the fight
you've got in you you're gonna just let
the erotic element of your life die and
and accept everything that goes along
with that because you're not willing to
cause a bit of trouble to ensure that
it's maintained and you know and we're
not very good at thinking these things
through consciously and I mean people
are bad at negotiating period as far as
I can tell but they're particularly bad
at negotiating things that are deeply
private how much do you want your
partner to know about you anyways it
takes a lot of trust to have a real
conversation about what you need and
want now you have in the press people
read that you are you have a following
of young men and I went to hear your
lecture and in Washington DC and there
were a lot of women there
your book I had first of all men don't
buy books that often compared to women
so I'm presuming you have a lot of
female readers and I found it Danielle
and I found it completely readable and
for men no it was no one it was more
like a delusional desire on the part of
the radical leftists that the only
people that could possibly be attracted
to me our Angry Men exam did be better
if they're angry young white men you
know grace then that fits the narrative
but yeah there's a it's an you have a
diverse audience in diverse following
including many women and they're also
not particularly angry
I mean I'm diffusing the anger that's
the point of your book is stop being yes
don't be resentful right well resentment
is that that's absolutely crippling
right resentment just zenman deceit
arrogance that's part of I'm writing
another book and one of the rules is
don't allow yourself to become resentful
resentful sweetville
deceitful and arrogant together yeah it
could be rad if you just write well
that's supposed to be a good thing so
yeah I mean there's been 250,000 people
as I said come to the lectures and there
hasn't been a single negative incident
know why this is what I find fascinating
is that I I found you early on I'd had
no idea you I just that it was like
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid like
who is that guy who is that guy but you
were pretty good and we were covering a
lot of the same topics later on and Wow
and then you know I found out who you
were what is astonishing to me is that
there's this amazing it just split
between the positivity of your audience
the diversity of your audience the the
intellectual content of your message and
then you get with a snarky journalist
with an agenda and I'm not mentioning
names but this he be this no baby no
this this young woman from GQ oh yeah
and it is beyond sight it was just like
you lady got you that was Channel four
we don't want to blame the BBC it was
Channel 4's
and then I and she seemed you know like
that's often she seemed intelligent and
capable of insight up to a point but
it's almost as if something had seized
her mind and she know something had
something I think people in the apology
Kamiya Polly says that a whole
generation some of our most talented
young women are incapable of thought
because of this idea where she thought
maybe you mean it's just an openness to
she couldn't and you were saying
completely like interesting fascinating
original things even to me who've
studied these topics and Wow and no it
was quite the day so I went to Baltimore
you said I did yeah well any but it made
me think a lot that day because I went
there and I had to go out of my way to
do it not that I'm complaining but
there's a reason for saying that you
know so I go out there Baltimore yeah
well I I was talking in Baltimore okay
so so and and I showed up to the to the
hotel room where this was all occurring
and you know what you expect generally
speaking even from journalists who
aren't you know who are more of the
attack dog variety or who maybe aren't
positively predisposed to you
ideologically or personally you expect a
certain modicum of professional
politeness right you know because well
you don't have to be there and you came
and you and you accepted an invitation
and all of that and so even with the
channel for journalist Kathy Newman
she was quite polite and and forthcoming
in the in the green room before the
interview you know it so she would had
at least that professional persona which
is it's not nothing right there there's
something to be said for for going
through the emotions professionally in
an appropriate manner but when I walked
into the hotel room in Baltimore it was
obvious that this interviewer had
already made up her mind about me a
hundred percent and that she was
absolutely you know negatively
predisposed to me with a personal animus
an animus is exactly the right word and
there was about a half an hour
photography session because it was GQ
and so I was
that atmosphere the photographers were
fine I was in that atmosphere for about
45 minutes before we started to talk and
part of the reason that I'm so I'm not
as calm during that interview as I
usually am I'm a little bit harsher and
the reason for that is that you know it
just started off instantly combative and
and what I what I should have done you
see it's very very difficult to be awake
enough to do these things properly and
and the interview progressed fine
although by the end of it I thought that
I had maybe done enough interviews for a
while because I didn't think I had
regulated my temper as well during that
interview as I might have well minutes
you were getting and then she brought up
a question about anger and I just saw
you kind of adjust and then after that
it was smooth sailing well that's good
because it was touch-and-go you know and
I thought boy you know maybe you're
running out of patience maybe you you
know maybe it's time to dial back on the
interviews because you know I've had
many interviews like that and they're
very I find them like and it takes me
like three days to recover I know and
then you got you start thinking yourself
like what I should have said I should
have saw that and I Drive myself mad no
but you did very well but it's so
interesting that what it told me was how
parochial she was and she lives in her
own little world isn't it more a little
bit about the ideology of our time and
gosh you encountered this everywhere and
I used to write about this wisely I put
I would encounter it I mean I think part
of the issue is that you will
acknowledge that there are differences
between the sexes that seems to be I
know that's a heresy that's a heresy
because when I was reading your book
there is nothing about it that is anti
female in fact you you do a lot of
examination of the Adam and Eve story
and you have this wonderful passage
about like Adam being the originally
aggrieved man who throws a woman under
the bus
oh dear it's her fault I'm broad you do
you made it's really funny so there's
nothing in this and the rules such as
they are you know they seem very
commonsensical they could apply to
anyone so is that it fair surmise of why
you get so attacked that just the very
fact that you're willing to speak about
the sexes as being not unequal but
different than equal yeah well you know
I would say that that's part of it
because there's a threat there so one of
the things that happen when I was in
Scandinavia I just wrote a call him
about this actually it was interesting
being in Scandinavia especially in
Sweden because they pushed the equality
of opportunity doctrine farther than any
other country they invented it it almost
started there and there like in the UN
and the original you know the Charter
the Swedes were there they they've never
given no no and so and the week that I
was there was the same week that two
articles were published on gender
differences in in temperament and in
interest and the biggest sex differences
that we know of that aren't
morphological are in interest so women
are more interested in people by and
large and men are more interested in
things by and large and the difference
is actually large it's one standard
deviation and so that means if you're a
man you would have to be more interested
in people than 85% of men to be as
interested as 50% of women and if you're
a woman you'd have to be more interested
in things than 85% of women to be as
interested as the 50th percentile male
so the difference is actually quite
substantial and it's certainly large
enough to drive occupational choice
differences and it which is also
explains a lot about the configuration
of people in the work oh absolutely well
and you know we're approach approaching
parity in terms of workplace overall
workplace distribution of women but
there's massive differences in
occupational choice like it's very
interesting for exam
to go to the website of the US Labor
Department and look at male and female
dominated industries and you know
there's the the top 10 male-dominated
industries has basically zero women in
them people requires being wonderful
like people there are people who zones
according to Camille Polly you find just
a lot of men in the people free zone
yeah and the women are in you ask a
group of women and men would you rather
spend the next three weeks taking apart
a machine and putting it together or
helping a group of people work out their
problems and the pool of people who want
to do the machine it's just far more men
than well and there's more men in women
dominated industries than there are
women and men dominated industries at
the extreme so that's nursing yeah
yes way more male nurses great where's
Ida studied these male nurses and they
already you know gender activists are
upset because they earn more than women
and a professor of Nursing at the
University of Pennsylvania tried to find
out why and she found out they
immediately find out what's the best
paying field
subfield so they go into like nurse
anesthesiology it pays a lot more the
men are there in disproportionate number
and they're willing to work in correct
you know insane hours they're far more
willing to with gender differences is
that men are more willing to move
they're more willing longer hours yeah
they're more willing to to work outside
they're more willing to take on
dangerous tasks they're more likely to
work in scalable industries so like you
can't scale personal care it's really
very it's very very difficult they're
much less likely to work part-time if
they have small businesses they're much
more likely to work full-time in the
small business rather than this then
part-time yeah and I mean women have
their reasons to want to work part-time
and Farrell also pointed out that if you
work ten percent longer hours you make
forty percent more money nonlinear
nonlinear return on overtime that's
something that's really useful to know
you know it's closer to an employer have
some but also marks you out you know
like if you have ten employees and
they're all doing the reasonable job
let's say but one of them is working an
extra half
now or a day or 45 minutes a day and you
can observe that every day then that
gives them an edge with regards to
potential promotion and so and the
return on those edges is nonlinear and
so anyways so I went to Scandinavia and
it was the same week that two studies
were released showing what had already
been established beyond a shadow of a
doubt that the personality differences
between men and women and the
differences in interest as well actually
get bigger as your society gets richer
and as it gets more egalitarian and and
not just a little bit either that's the
other thing that's so interesting is you
might think well the effect is it's the
opposite of what the social
constructionist would predict first of
all so that's the first thing to point
out is it's not only that their
hypothesis wasn't supported it was
decidedly refuted and and none of them
have come to terms with that and and and
it's not a small effect the the the
difference between personality between
men and women in Scandinavia is a lot
larger than it is in Nani Gillett aryan
khan tract in rural that's also true in
the united states the richer the
democratic your household demographic
your household the more likely the woman
is to take town time out and be at home
with you right if you can afford to do
it and she can afford to major in what
odd you know low-paying fields like I
don't know a feminist dance therapy one
of the things that's also interesting I
think is that you know there's this idea
that made that marriage is a patriarchal
institution you know that's primarily
put there for the for the utility of the
of the male and think well like I think
that's complete bloody rubbish and I
don't think there's any evidence to
support it at all but I think the best
counter evidence is that well if that's
the case then rich people shouldn't be
getting married because they don't have
to oppress themselves but the truth of
the matter is is that the higher your
demographic position the more likely you
are to be married so marriage is falling
apart among you know and the more likely
the wife is staying home and but not I
mean she will has all sorts of pursuits
but she's not well there's an old saying
anyone any woman who marries for money
earns it
but now let me just okay this is where
you might get in a little trouble
because in your book you call men order
and women chaos and you say order the
known appears symbolically associated
with masculinity and chaos the eternal
feminine is also the crushing force of
sexual select yeah what's up with that
yeah chaotic okay well it isn't men and
women that are ordering chaos it's
masculinity and femininity symbolically
and so what's happened fundamentally is
that where our brains are wired for
social cognition so we're not natural
scientists who are natural sociologists
that might be of bidders even though I
shudder to think that that might be true
especially maybe so yes well that's it
okay triggering or maybe yeah or me or
maybe we're more or more naturally
people who observe through the lens of
fiction and that what we see is the
world as characterized and the world
obviously is made out of men and women
and children and those seem to be our
fundamental cognitive categories
masculinity femininity and and and and
then the category of children and those
categories have expanded to take on
connotations outside of of pure person
perception and so you know it's for this
reason that if you go to a movie and
then maybe it's a Disney animated movie
and I like to talk about those because
they draw on a very deep symbolic well
it's perfectly reasonable to see a witch
that lives in a swamp because those go
together like it makes sense you know
the witch doesn't live in a gleaming
chrome high-rise you know she lives in a
swamp because that's important room I
think well that's it that's well the
hybrids would be better for that right
but there are categories of symbolic
association that are natural to the way
we think and the fundamental elements of
those categories seem to be gendered and
so this is partly why I make reference
to Taoism for example so for the Daoists
the world is made out of chaos and order
and chaos is the domain that you don't
understand
that emerges unpredictably but also the
domain from which new forms emerge right
because it's from novelty that the new
emerges and I think the fundamental
association between femininity is chaos
is the association between what's
unexpected and novel and what's new
because new forms emerge from chaos and
it's not that chaos is is bad an order
is good that that's no book both have
their pathology both have their Burchett
yeah yes and and and what you're looking
for and this is this is but the book
concentrates on above all is that you're
looking constantly to find the balance
between those two so for example
formally speaking the domain of order is
that place that you are when what you're
doing is producing the results that you
want to have produced so imagine imagine
think about the preconditions for not
being anxious okay so the preconditions
are that you're constantly making
predictions about what's going to happen
next
and those predictions are tied tightly
to your behavioral output so you act in
a certain way and you presume that a
certain thing is going to happen and if
your actions produce the results that
you desire then you assume that you know
where you are and you know what you're
doing and that your plan is intact and
that the environment is secure and that
keeps your anxiety under control that's
order and then you know maybe you're at
a party and you don't know anybody and
you tell a joke and everybody looks at
you like what you said was not only not
funny but also downright offensive and
then all of a sudden you've moved from
the domain of order into the domain of
chaos because you thought you were
somewhere and you thought you were
someone and you were thought you were
with people that were of a certain type
and you got all that wrong and so if it
is gonna be the woman who says I find
that really open but women are also more
sensitive to negative emotion so there
is some slightly higher probability that
that might be the case but then I think
women are also associated at least in
men's imaginations with nature which is
part of the chaotic domain say as
opposed to culture because
they're sexually selective so you've got
to think what is nature I mean we have
that as a cognitive category right we
think of the natural world and think of
nature versus culture it's a fundamental
opposition what is nature well nature is
trees and landscapes and animals and all
of that but that isn't what nature
fundamentally is nature fundamentally is
that which selects from a genetic
perspective that's nature that's the
fundamental definition of nature and it
is the case that human females are
sexually selective and it's it's a major
component of human behavior so the
evolutionary theory roughly speaking is
that the reason we diverged from
chimpanzees eight million years ago 7
million years ago is at least in part
because of the differences between
sexual selectivity between female humans
and female chimpanzees female
chimpanzees are more likely to have
offspring from dominant males but it's
not because of their sexual selectivity
so a female chimpanzee has periods of
fertility that are marked by physical by
observable physiological changes not the
case with human females human female
ovulation is is concealed so that's a
very profound biological difference
between human females and chimpanzees
and the chimpanzee females will mate
with any male but the dominant males
chase the subordinate males away but
human females are sexually selective and
so and it's not a trivial fact so you
have twice as many female ancestors as
male ancestors you think well how can
that be
well imagine that on average every
single human female has had one child
throughout the entire course of history
which is approximately correct by the
way then imagine that half of the man
had zero and the other half had two okay
and that's roughly the case so half of
males historically speaking have been
repres and the reason for that is
because of female sexual selectivity so
it is actually the case that female
humans are nature it's not only that
they're that that they're associated
with me
symbolically as far as repre they are
the force of nature that does the
selection and so their nature in the
most fundamental way and there is a
chaotic element of that at least in
relationship to men and also in
relationship to women because a lot of
the female on female competition is
competition
that's chaotic for the right to be
sexually selective right not only with
regards to men which drives a lot of
politicking but also in relationship to
each other because part of what human
females do is jockey for position in the
female dominance hierarchy for the top
position which is the woman who gets to
be most sexually selective and so that
draws female female competition and it's
a different dynamic there's there's
similarities between female female
competition and male-male competition
but there are also differences and
they're pronounced so men for example
while men are more likely to compute
compete for socioeconomic status and
that's partly because that drives female
made choice so the correlation for men
between socioeconomic status and sexual
success is about 0.6 and for women it's
0-0 in fact it's actually slightly
negative so and that's a huge difference
between men and women but you know that
you know the anthropologist Sarah hurdie
Hrdy
and she's like my favorite feminist
theorist although as she would say I'm a
theorist who happens to be a feminist
but she studied primate behavior and she
watched she looked at the women very
care they were the females and I was
very carefully and looked at it
chimpanzees and gazelles and found that
the female minissha Lee liked male
primatologists would look and say oh the
females the males are dominant and the
females are so cooperative she looked
more carefully and so the females
weren't exactly cooperative like they
would pass around their infants their
baby you know whatever they were and but
fine and so the male primatologist say
oh they're they're so kind and caring
she found out that when it was not your
it was not hers
they would take little Tufts of
here would come out or they do something
to the eyes and and the baby would like
be injured and she saw all this violence
especially true in their status
differentiation yes so that's much more
likely that'll happen when a higher
status female is taking care of a lower
status infant exactly and she said the
great tragedy
well not tragedy she said the reality of
our species and in fact the subtitle for
the book is the woman who never evolved
we didn't evolve for niceness and
cooperative there's an immense
competition and we can according to her
we are its indelibly you know marked in
our nature to compete for the dominant
males there's in so and that seems to
cross culturally as well that does
flatten out a little bit in the more
egalitarian societies yeah instead of
being exaggerated it does flatten to
some degree okay so you could imagine
that there's a biological component and
a cultural component and both in in in
that case if you modify the cultural
component then that seems to decrease
the overall so like let me be more clear
about this women are less prone to mate
up across an up status hierarchies in
Scandinavia than they are in less
egalitarian countries but they're still
prone to do it so worldwide for example
women young women find men who are about
four years older than them maximally
attractive and they tend to mate across
and up status hierarchies and so one of
the consequences of that for example is
that as women have entered the workforce
they've actually driven inequality
because rich women will only marry rich
men men as rich as them or richer
whereas rich men will marry women who
are poorer than them but women won't and
so what that means is it's another
factor that's pooling wealth in the
hands of fewer and fewer people this is
a sort of mating now and you just find
someone with your background you wear as
a doctor might have once married is
secretary you now marries another doctor
yeah well can I ask then stepping a
little bit back from primates as well
how does this selection work in the era
of swiping right and left
how what is your reaction to the way
young people date today oh that's a good
I was really hoping we'd get into that
you were very into the monkeys so I
didn't want to interrupt no no well well
I should close off the Scandinavian
discussion just by pointing out and this
is something that the Scandinavians are
really going to have to wrestle with is
that if you Institute effective policies
to promote equality of opportunity which
the Scandinavians have done you're going
to produce some equality so like a 50-50
distribution of men and women in the
workplace but you're also going to
exacerbate certain kinds of inequality
and you can't get out of that so you
cannot have equality of opportunity and
equality of outcome together they don't
work together an equality of outcomes
the essential equality of outcome
doctrine which is often described with
the code word equity is that at every
level of every occupation the people
have to be represented by the same
number that they're represented in at
the population so if it's not 5050 men
and women at each in each occupation any
and in each strata at each occupation
then that sort of prima facie evidence
for discrimination and for systemic
discrimination it's like nope sorry you
have to factor in choice and choice
actually turns out to be a very
important determinant and as this
society gets flatter and flatter choice
becomes a more important a more and more
important determinant and so you so what
that essentially means is that the most
radical end of the left-wing political
agenda is logically impossible it's
impossible for a variety of other
reasons and they should look at the data
I mean it it's just a cliche now of in a
group of activists and they'll say oh
well we need in order for women to
achieve equality we need government
funded day care and we need they have it
in Sweden yeah Sweden has fewer women in
managerial levels American women are
ahead in fact now they have Jenna they
have quotas over there so they need
female CEOs and females on board hasn't
made any difference
they're bringing in mmmm
and women because we're so much further
ahead it's like no difference in the
distribution of men and women lower than
them no it's it's called the Nordic
paradox and okay you guys are so wonky
I'm gonna get back okay yeah yes that's
good good well we all want to get back -
get back - monkeys well I was thinking
this morning about I was talking to a
variety of political types and we were
talking about this morning yeah in DC
it's hard to believe hard to believe no
I'm not I'm not telling you a bunch of
Republicans here and I've been talking
to Democrats as well but it was mostly
Republicans here and we were talking
about abortion and I made a case that
that's really not a very productive
discussion because you're talking about
a problem way too late in the sequence
of problems so by the time the
discussion starts to be about abortion
there's 50 problems that have already
emerged that no one has addressed and
some of those problems are the
fundamental problem is how human beings
should regulate their sexual behavior
and that's a big problem and you think
well and there's an interesting thing
that's happening because you know the
people on the right would say well
that's easy is I don't sleep around and
and get married and have sex with your
marital partner and that's all the
problem so there's strictures on sexual
behavior and those would be the
traditional ones and what you see on the
left is that there's this weird
paradoxical demand let's say that people
should be allowed to express their
sexuality in any manner that they choose
whenever they want but that sex is so
dangerous that it has to be carefully
regulated at every single stage of the
interaction and so you know that many
state legislatures have now followed the
example of university campuses and put
it in affirmative consent legislation so
that every move you make towards
physical intimacy has to be preceded by
the instantiation of a verbal contract
essentially it's like well can I take
your hand yes you actually from what I
understand you actually have to say yes
like nodding is not sufficient
and so and so each stage has to be it
has to be preceded by affirmative
consent and you know which which well I
won't I won't say anything about yeah I
will it's absurd it's absurd to assume
that that's how human intimate
relationships are supposed to proceed
and then you have complicated laws
emerging that are part of that that for
example this is the case in California
as I understand it is that you cannot
give affirmative consent if you're
intoxicated okay so you think about that
it's like well what does that mean it
means that like a lot of sex uses it has
been illegal for a long time including
marital marital yes it's nice to me on
my honeymoon
okay well buddy I'm rethinking it it's
it seems to me it seems to me it seems
to me to mean the California legislation
that if you have sex with your wife or
husband and either of you is intoxicated
then you're either one of you or both is
guilty of rape that's what it looks like
to me actually I was in a debate a few
years ago at the University of Virginia
law school and I turned to my debate
partner and said so if what you're
saying is right
two people can rape one another hmm
right she said yes oh I mean how can
that be well that that's the question
well okay so then I would say well it's
interesting because I think that a lot
of this confusion has emerged
fundamentally as a consequence of the
birth control pill so you know cuz you
got to think situationally before you
think ideologically or psychologically
it's like it seems to me that the 20th
century will be remembered for the
hydrogen bomb the transistor and the
birth control pill and those are
unbelievably radical technological
innovations and maybe the most ornate
cannon
yeah but might fairly fairly it's
dependent on the transistor you know cuz
it's spawned all of that so that that's
the big technological
innovation that spawned all that and of
the three I would say the the birth
control pill is probably the bigger
hydrogen bomb so and because it it
changed the fundamental biological
nature of women and men and because it
gave women for the first time in
biological history the the option of
choosing their reproductive status yeah
and that's that's we like that that's
absol yes and no like yes we like it but
it's not something that's come without a
tremendous complexity a fellow can know
well I'm not I'm not making a case for
the abolition of the birth control pill
by any stretch of the imagination but
I'm pointing at its complexity and so
because one of the questions is well
once you can regulate your reproductive
function what attitude should you have
towards sex and one answer might be the
more of it under the more varied
circumstances the better because why not
and I would say that was actually part
of the attitude that emerged in the
aftermath of the birth control pill in
the nineteen sixties right and it was it
was a reasonable response in some sense
because it's such a cataclysmic change
that you don't know what it implies well
what's the consequence of that well
first of all people aren't reliable
enough to use birth control in an
entirely reliable manner so even though
it can work at near a hundred percent
efficiency you have to take it
extraordinarily regularly and in a
disciplined manner for that to work and
so there was still the problem of
unwanted pregnancy let's say and then
there was the problem of the
proliferation of sexual epidemics and
that culminated in aids which you know
could have easily wiped all of us out
but didn't but there are other sexual
epidemics that could have had the same
effect but we've been fortunate enough
to escape them and and then and then
more recently there's been this weird
inversion especially on the radical left
that points to the re-emergence of
something like a set of sex
taboos you know like I think the idea
that sex is casual and that it's a form
of entertainment is I think it's an
absolutely preposterous idea I think
that it's it's psychologically shallow
beyond belief to hold that as a core
proposition because it forces you to
first of all if if it's repetitive sex
with multiple partners it it forces you
to treat people as if they're
interchangeable and I don't see how
that's good for you psychologically or
for the people that you're using
interchangeably it it implies that you
can divorce sexuality from play from the
desire for it for a relationship from
emotional fragility from love from
family from responsibility all of those
things that are part and parcel of
everyone and I don't think you can and I
don't think people's experience
indicates that you can and especially on
the emotional front and I think that's
partly what's driving and there's also a
residual sense that there's something
about sex that's fundamentally dangerous
and maybe it's dangerous emotionally and
personally and maybe it's dangerous
socially and psychologically which it
most certainly is because it's a
powerful force and the way the left is
reacting to that is by insisting that
all forms of sexual behavior are valid
and and and that it's reasonable to
manifest all of them but that it's
simultaneously so dangerous that
absolutely every aspect of it has to be
state regulated and in an increase in
English Akoni inform and so I think what
needs to happen is that the left and the
right have to get together and have a
like a real discussion about what
constitutes fell in sexual morality and
that's the conversation you have to have
way before you worry about solving like
the abortion debate which you know is
very divisive and very and very
intractable well one of the things we
talked about actually just last week on
the podcast is this cover story in
Atlantic about the sexual recession
among young people that despite the
advent of the birth control pill
abortion is is going down it's that
there's that there's Lex
and I think is going down look up fewer
odds have you can't look into that
you're a bad thing on that well if you
raise the cost of something you decrease
its prevalence you know and and I think
that it's it seems to be you know a
Juris now don't you look up well I know
what I kind of think that it's also a
reflection of the same thing that
bloomberg reported on just a few days
ago they said that across businesses men
are thinking I'm not spending any time
with a single woman that isn't you know
associated with me in some formal manner
like my wife I'm not going to do it I'm
not going to mentor young women I'm not
going to be in a room alone with them
because I could face career annihilation
absolutely and instantly they're
frightened of young women escape Julian
said that's part of it but we can over
exaggerate the part I mean anxiety and
depression is going up amongst both
young men and young women suicide is
going up that that there's it's not just
a you know most people I think are not
we're talking about an elite demographic
who is into the consent and political
correctness and work play there this is
across the board and its global it's in
it's happening even in Sweden it's
really happening in Japan yeah and Japan
exactly so so weird things are and that
speaks to and especially in Japan they
have people especially young men have
given up on intimacy and that having sex
is actually I mean that have too much
trouble sex robots right well right well
and there's pornography yeah there's
basically zero risk when you allow for
pornography that that that men and women
will sort of separate that from their
actual cyclic anyway we're seeing a
whole
I guess collapse of intimacy hmm let
alone sex and and and and and I don't
think that's just explained by the
political nature so I I'd be interested
in your thoughts yeah well I don't know
that I don't know the literature on the
decline in sexual activity well enough
to know if it's valid or reliable mm-hmm
but I mean I mean I think that you know
in a stable society you take lots of
things for granted you take you take the
fact that men and women are going to be
searched
we attracted to one another for granted
and even though it's more fragile than
it appears you know it and it's
suppressed more easily than you might
think
and you take the idea that men and women
are going to move together towards the
establishment of long-term intimate
relationships for granted but that's
partly because you don't understand what
invisible preconditions exist to make
that self-evident you know and when
those invisible preconditions are
disrupted by rapid technological or
sociological change then things shift
underneath you and you don't know why
like a lot of it is traced to the advent
of the smartphone especially in the
generation Z that that a Kate was
explaining this to us that you could see
it was broadband internet and the
smartphone that led to this you know
increasing fall off relationships yeah
well maybe the abstract is more
interesting than right you see that I
want to know the truth have you ever
been with somebody you loved and I'm
fascinating all that but you really want
to get back to your smartphone has that
ever happened
yeah well all the time to me know
happens during our podcast I'm research
they're very they're very addictive you
know I read the other day that they're
very alluring like they are kind of
going together the preferred method of
interpersonal communication between
young people now is testing rather than
face-to-face communication right and the
swiping the Apes
yeah well that's that's a whole that's
that's a very interesting topic to that
the like the tinder phenomenon that's
because that that's an also a major
technological revolution because what
it's done I would say for the first time
is reduce the cost of rejection to males
to zero because it hides it the only
people you ever hear from our people who
haven't rejected you although although
they true but but there was one man who
had to make 300 he key actually tallied
it yeah he had to make 300 requests of
swiping right to one replies already he
had
sense of sure sure sure but it's
massively attenuated because you're not
being humiliated not at all not at all
it's real it's really at arm's length
and you know you can swipe very very
rapidly and so you can get all that
rejection over within a very short
period or less be worse not I mean not
nearly as bad yeah so and you know I I
don't know what and I mean tinder also
reduces the one of the other things that
things that you want to think about with
regards to sex and I think this is
probably particularly true for women is
that to what degree is it in women's
interests to allow the cost of sex to
fall to zero because with pornography
certainly does that and it just seems to
me that that's not a very good long-term
strategy for relationships between men
and women because whatever sex is worth
the cost of zero is the wrong price
mm-hm and so that's you know bunnyranch
and paid quite a bit for it well true
true maybe but that's true but you know
you don't have to and you know I've
heard from a number of women what
written read blog reports on their
frustration with their attempts to be
relatively sexually selective like let's
say they decide that they're not going
to sleep with their new partner on the
first date you know they're frustrated
by the fact that to the degree that
they're being cautious in their sexual
behavior which i think is actually an
admirable idea that they're instantly
out competed especially if their
partners are somewhat impulsive by women
who will say yes at the drop of a hat
and so well again I don't think you know
it depends on what the goal is that's
the thing is that there's the short
terms they're short term sexual
gratification but the literature
indicates that married couples for
example or couples in a permanent
long-term monogamous relationship are
more sexually satisfied than single
people and maybe the single people have
to be parsed out into those who are
sexually successful and those who aren't
but I suspect that wouldn't make that
much difference but whatever there's the
utility of relatively immediate sexual
gratification for whatever that's worth
and the adventurousness that goes along
with that let's
say the hunt and the excitement of
having a new partner and all of that and
maybe even the danger that's associated
with that because people like to have a
little bit of danger in their life but
what's the goal it's like what do people
want and I mean there's a great book
called a billion wicked thoughts that
was written by Google engineers and so
it contains great psychology because
Google engineers don't care about
political correctness and they just
write down what they find they don't
even notice that it's politically
incorrect
hence James to more for example and what
they found was that women use
pornography just as much as men but the
pornography that women use is verbal
it's not imagistic and that the
pornographic novels essentially follow
the same extraordinarily standard
plotline to the degree that publishing
houses like Harlequin I was gonna say
it's the it's the bodice rippers that's
right snob yeah right so in the
Harlequin series you have you know the
ones that were published like in the
1970s that are pretty tame well there's
a variety they may reign they range from
rapidly tame to essentially to hardcore
pornography Bucky but the plots are
quite similar and the plot is you know
young relatively innocent woman finds
powerful interesting dangerous male
tames him and then they live happily
ever after
yeah it's the beauty in the beasts plot
his search for women on pornhub we
discovered we did an episode on porn was
for women it was getting rape wasn't
that like there's no lesbianism or at
least that was your port yeah that was
yours That's not me okay my porn is
going to the williams-sonoma store I
know it is it is female all those know
it Bill Maher once said men and women
should never tell one another their
fantasies because when they're outraged
by what we say and we're totally bored
by what they say and I thought like
women have kind of these scenarios and
you know I don't know unicorns I don't
know what their storyline storylines and
mentors like I don't want to say this to
you but if there's a lot of just
close-ups of female body parts yeah
men are much more visually oriented I
know sexually and but now they're being
shamed I mean now that it's called the
male gaze mm-hm and so there's all of
this thing oh my god the Sports
Illustrated is exploiting the female
forget it yeah I mean men like it and
I'm worried that now sort of the way in
the past sexual stuff you know gays were
shamed we're now reversing it and
shaming like heterosexual
yes that's different remember we had the
young woman who complained about being
whistled at and I said don't worry it
stops yeah do we have a little bit of
time for a couple more topics with you
because one of the things that is coming
out of this younger generation and you
have a chapter of it in your book which
I'm sorry I wanted to finish what the
line that we were pursuing I do this
well with sexual behavior the question
is what's the endgame and then this is
what people have to ask themselves is
like one of the corollaries to the
female pornographic romance is actually
the establishment of a long-term
relationship and the question is you
know it's so funny because I got
pilloried in the New York Times for
talking about enforced monogamy squirty
because that gets brought up like in
every I talked to that woman for to two
days I know it's just like a little side
comment and then that became like a
showcase like like in forced monogamy
you mean forced marriage or no I mean
that was an anthropological term which
she knew perfectly well because she's a
very smart person and all it means is
that there's a pronounced proclivity in
human societies around the world to
enforce monogamous relationships at
multiple levels of the sociological
hierarchy you do it culturally do it you
do it in expectation you do it legally
you know an enforced monogamy so if my
son was just married and if he came to
me next year and he said you know okay
dad guess what I've managed to have four
Affairs in the last year with hot women
and my wife hasn't found out about any
of them I'm not going to pat him on the
back and say good job kid you know I'm
gonna say what the hell's up with you
you know you violated the vow that you
took you're putting your whole future at
risk you're betraying yourself and your
wife and well that's enforced monogamy
you know the the idea is that the social
norm is
the establishment of a long-term
monogamous relationship and that there
are strictures put in place to support
that but also to punish deviation from
it and you say well you know maybe maybe
not so much on the punishment end but
you can't it depends it's like what do
you want what what is it that you want
you want a long-term stable relationship
or not and if that's the goal then your
behavior should be devoted to whatever
it is that facilitates that goal and I
don't see that I certainly don't see
that casual and impulsive sex fits that
bill not in the least
and all of the evidence with regards to
living together shows that that's
actually detrimental to the
establishment of a long-term
relationship so first of all common-law
marriage people who are in common-law
marriage are much more likely to be
divorced so that's the first thing the
second thing is people who live together
before they get married are much more
likely to be divorced after they get
married so the idea that well you can
try someone on for size and see how it
works and then you're gonna see if
you're compatible it's like that's one
story another story is how about you and
I live together for a little while and
you know if you're you're not so bad but
maybe I can find someone better and if I
do you know in the next year and a half
or so because we're not hooked together
in any formal way I can just trade you
in it's okay you can do the same to me
but I don't really see that as the sort
of complementary mutual interaction that
leads to the formulation of long term
trust and I think it's a better story
for interpreting what constitutes living
together then well you know we're gonna
try each other out because that's what
mature people would do that's a rental
yeah well that's right watch the rental
yeah yeah well that's that's it and and
but what more most importantly the data
indicate that it doesn't work is that
you're more likely to get divorced not
less likely because maybe the right
attitude is well you're probably about
as flawed as me and you know we're lucky
that we found each other and so let's
see if we can make a commitment because
we're engaging in something that's very
risky you know an intimate relationship
and we're going to commit to each other
and see if we can build something of
value across time and there's a definite
of risk in that but there's a complement
to your partner it's like well I think
you're worth making a sacrifice for and
what's the sacrifice well
everyone else it's a big sacrifice and
there's and if you don't see that as a
compliment then I don't think you're
thinking because not only is it a
compliment it's sort of like the
ultimate compliment and maybe you don't
get to have a marriage that works
without that compliment maybe it's so
difficult to establish a long-term
relationship that's functional that you
have to make a walloping sacrifice very
early on in the relationship in order
for that to even be a possibility and
you know maybe not because what the hell
do we know about what binds people
together but but it's not that easy to
stay with someone for a long period of
time you know it's it's a real it's a
real commitment it takes a tremendous
amount of effort so yes I thought
actually you're bringing us back to the
beginning and your time with Tammy and
one of the things about I think I'm
gonna guess this is a bit of an
overlooked part in your chapter in your
book but I just was like one of my
favorites it was your book on modern
parenting oh yes and that was the one I
thought I would get in most trouble for
I know but critics don't read that far
into the book well well it my mother
when I had my first child gave me a
1950s copy of dr. Spock and he was
considered so controversial and yet he's
just like a most sensible person made
new children very very well was a
pediatrician and you your rule for
parenting is do not let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them and
you kind of in that one chapter and it's
not even one of your longest chapters
just did this wonderful sweeping
overview of modern parenting and the
problems and in some ways that we're
producing maybe some of these kids who
are prolonging adulthood prolonging the
markers of adulthood that that you feel
that parents you said you see today's
parents is terrified by their children
not least because they've denied credit
for their role as benevolent and
necessary agents of discipline order and
conventionality and then you told some
hilarious stories about when your wife
ran a daycare center out of your house
and you would you would get into tests
of wills with some of the two-year-olds
but son is ornery
married yeah he still doesn't want to do
anything he doesn't want to do yes he's
very charming
yeah and very emotionally stable so it's
like he's easy to get along with but
trying to get him to do something he
doesn't want to do it's alright
he had my wife defeated when he was nine
months old and she's top like seriously
she's no pushover but he would just sit
there with his mouth closed and glare at
hers like I'm not eating that and I can
take more than you can dish out it was
really something to see you know to see
that kind of force of will in someone
not small talk a little bit about that
and just the modern roles between men
and women I mean we're less you know
they're you don't really you're not
really supposed to distinguish between
fathers and mothers even though that
seems to inevitably happen in most well
it happens in large part because the
children differentiate between them like
parents are under the delusion that most
of what you do with your children is
driven by what you want to do with your
children when in fact it's driven to a
massive degree by what your children
want you to do with them and so there
were studies done 30 years ago on
feminist parents who decided that they
were going to raise their children in
non gender differentiated manners and
when they were studied they found that
the parents who had that explicit
philosophy were just as gender
differentiated with their children as
the parents who didn't have the
philosophy and the reason for that is
that if you're a parent that has any
sense at all you don't respond to your
children as a rigid ideologue you
respond to them as whatever it is the
child man manifests him in or herself as
like you know with any individualized
relationship you take your cue from the
person and you might think while a child
has no intrinsic nature but you know if
you think that you either don't have
children or you've never seen a child or
you're so blinded by your Radiology that
you don't have a child you just have a
blank projection screen onto which you
project your presuppositions and then
heaven help your child you know so so a
lot of the gender differentiation is
actually driven by the children's
demands and and that's all for the good
that chapter I thought I would get into
tremendous trouble for writing that
chapter because it's contentious right
on the surface just the rule because the
rule first implies that children can be
dislikable and then I would say again
you know it's like have you met children
exactly a child where they're children
you didn't like obviously and it's a
lots of children are dislikeable but
it's taboo to admit that because they're
all sweetness and light and innocence
ever since Rousseau but you know who so
put all five of his children in an
orphanage where they all died so maybe
we won't know so we won't talk too much
about Rousseau and and then the next
taboo is well that parents can dislike
their children but if you're a clinician
and you don't think that parents can
dislike their children then well then
well then you're not a clinician because
one of the things you constantly see is
that pathology within families is an
incredibly common source of
psychological destabilization right and
it's terrible tension between parents
and their children and between siblings
what I suggest in them in the book which
i think is radical by today's standards
is that your fundamental job as a parent
is to ensure that by the time your child
is four years old that they are
maximally desirable to other children
and two adults because what happens is
that after the age of four
you aren't the primary agent of
socialization the social world becomes
the primary agent of socialization and
if your child is the sort of child
that's
invited to play by other children
because your child is capable of four
strolling gratification and taking turns
and playing someone else's game when
when it's necessary and abiding by the
rules and not having a temper tantrum
when they lose and not getting to you
know high on their horse when they win
then many children will invite them I
don't know what do you know I know we
have we have our limited time and so I
just wanted to I was actually saying any
more question because I really want to
hear you talk well I know I just want to
let him victus I'll take 15 seconds to
wrap that up and then
well so look you get married when you
have your children and you're flawed and
your partner's flawed and hopefully
you're flawed in different ways and so
you put the two of you together and you
make one approximately normal person and
then hopefully and then your child has
to interact with that dyad that is a
reasonable representative of social
norms and if they discipline if your
child disappoints you with their
behavior the probability that they will
disappoint other people is very high and
so you have an ethical obligation to
ensure that your child is behaving in a
manner that makes them optimally
desirable to their playmates and also to
other adults because then people the
kids invite them to play and they get to
be socialized right they get they have
friends for God's sake is like what do
you want for your kids how about some
friends wouldn't that be nice
and maybe what you'd like is that they
regulate their behavior well enough so
that when you take them places
restaurants to see your friends to see
your relatives they behave in a manner
that sufficiently civilized so their
intrinsic charm wins over the adults and
everywhere they go people are smiling
and welcoming instead of wishing with
fake smiles that the damn brat would
leave along with their foolish parents
which is not a good
that's not a good environment to have
your child constantly exposed to no
friends because they're too selfish and
immature and irritated your irritating
to adults so that they're barely
tolerated under the mask of false smiles
it's like you have an ethical obligation
to regulate your child's behavior so
that they're optimally acceptable
socially and that is not how people look
at children in the modern world they
think well you're raising their
self-esteem or you're enhancing their
creativity or you don't want to put
constraints on their behavior because
you're going to interfere with the
flowering of their intrinsic self and
you know it's all Rousseau in nonsense
and there's no evidence for it you know
yeah he was such a corrupt and he had
these babies with this poor scullery
maid and left them all in a actually a
place where they would
languish and die yeah right five of them
Rousseau yeah I know I know yeah exactly
oh and it's intrinsically good yeah but
I just remember a few weeks ago I was I
really met you and and somehow I got
onto somebody's twitter feed whom I will
not mention because oh my god but anyway
a difficult person and she was attacking
you and had a selection from your book a
way you had called two-year-olds little
monsters and so suddenly all of these
distraught Twitter followers of this
feminist were saying there are monsters
you know and then there'd be a thing
kind of hard and they had taken this out
of context and shown it like just
something to deplore it and it was so
amusing to me this little hopefully
they'll soon be cursed I won't say which
one was two years old and had he was a
good boy but he had an insane meltdown
in a supermarket I was with my mother
we both pretended we didn't know yeah we
heard people say oh my god Oh haven't
watching a two-year-old have a tantrum
is it so it was like I didn't want to be
a we had a boy who used to be in like
when my wife was taking care of more
kids than ours there was a little boy
who had learned to throw a pretty decent
- yes and and he would do that and it
didn't work in our house because we just
leave him have his tantrum and going
into a different room and then he'd kind
of wake up out of it there wouldn't be
anybody around and so that like if you
put all that words audience romatic
display and you had a zero audience it's
not you're not gonna sustain it anyways
he could actually hold his breath until
he turned blue so you should try that to
go home and see if you can do that in
front of the mirror man like it's hard
it's very very guys love tiring will you
do it was impressive it was and and you
know two-year-olds are very impressive
they're there they have unbelievable
outbursts of rage and and disinhibited
emotion and your job is you know they're
they're driven by these underlying
motivational systems that are
unbelievably powerful and it's part of
what makes them delightful because when
they're happy they're insanely happy and
when they're playful they're incredibly
playful and so the positive end of them
is is way exaggerated compared to you
know a rather drab adult and and so it
makes two-year-olds extraordinarily
interesting but the same is true on the
negative emotion side they're completely
dysregulated and it's really hard on
them like to have a two-year-old who
isn't in control of their emotions means
that you have a child who's developing
central personality you know their their
ego for black of a better word is
constantly being swamped by these
powerful underlying emotional systems
you know what it's like if you are
enraged for any period of time or if
you're engulfed by grief like it's
exhausting it's it's it's demeaning and
it's exhausting and it's the same with a
little kid it's like it's a real defeat
for the developing integrated individual
to be subjugated by those catastrophic
ly powerful emergent emotions and part
of your job as a parent is to scaffold
the part of the child that can regulate
and inhibit those powerful underlying
systems so with my son for example when
he used to misbehave I would count and
say you're gonna go sit on the steps
he'd say oh no I'm not I should say oh
yes you are and then usually I'd have to
chase him around because he wouldn't go
sit on the steps and so I'd put him on
the steps say you're gonna sit there
until you've got yourself under control
and so he'd say no I not say yes you are
and then he tried to get up and I just
told him say you're gonna sit there I'm
gonna hold you till you sit there no I'm
not it's like I could oh wait a
two-year-old so I usually won those
battles and then he'd sit there I said
look kid this is the deal it's two
things like you wanna have a bad day or
you want have a good day you think about
that because if you don't have a good
day bad day we could have a bad days you
sit here as soon as you can control
yourself and you're ready to be
civilized then you can come back and we
can have a good day
so we'd sit there
just-just I was unbelievable to watch
just enveloped with rage you know just
trying to get himself under control you
know and so I'd come back 30 seconds
later and I'd say you know what let's
got yourself your act together ya know
you're here I'm so darn wait and usually
it took him two or three minutes and
he'd calm down and then he'd come back
out and you'd say I'm ready to have a
good day and he meant it you know and I
could tell he meant it too because
whatever resentment I was harboring
towards him for his misbehavior and you
have to watch that when you're an adult
would vanish because he'd come and he he
was done he was ready just you know to
proceed on a civilized basis it was
really interesting to watch that because
it took him every time he sat on the
steps it took him a shorter and shorter
period of time to attain mastery right
until you know it got to the point where
he could only have to sit for 15 seconds
or so when he would bring himself under
control and that was a victory like you
if you imagine the neurological systems
developed they're responsible for
personality integration it was a victory
for those systems because they were
attaining the ability to regulate the
lower order spontaneous emotions and you
know and and he turned into an
individual who's capable of a tremendous
level of self control and you know and
he had large deep yes absolutely
well it turned out well for my daughter
too because she ended up being very ill
and he ended up being extraordinarily
level-headed and reliable and thank God
for that
could you could you come to my house and
do that for my little Maltipoo Izzy
because I I can't cheat I can't I can't
train her she's like a wonder nice the
next book the dog I would love to train
your dog before yeah yeah well I that's
the one rule what's with petting the cat
I wrote about dogs for two pages to
begin with just to satisfy the dog it
didn't satisfy you can't satisfy them
alright well we can't thank you enough
for coming here I know the AEI audience
is just so delighted to have had the
chance to hear you well I'm really happy
good
to talk my weights of torque I've only
met you like once we met in DC but I
just see you passed electrons yes oh you
swiped
oh yeah well there was that we're not
going into that
[Applause]